the top narrative that the left has been
pushing these days is on race probably
the most ridiculous conspiracy theory
they have is that there's such a thing
as white supremacy in the united states
institutional supremacy never mind that
the left runs all the institutions
systemic racism
whatever term you want to use that
basically white people have privilege
they can do whatever they want they get
an advantage in society
black people can never succeed no matter
what they do they're hopelessly
oppressed
and kept down so what's the reality of
the situation we talked yesterday on the
show
about how there's only one example of
legal racism in this country there's
there's just one
and it doesn't go along with the leftist
narrative it's called affirmative action
and it privileges black and hispanic
applicants to college and
to employ into employment and it
disadvantages white
and asian applicants and that's why
right now the doj civil rights office is
looking into
yale university for doing just that
that's racial discrimination on the
books that's institutional racism
left doesn't talk about that though
because that doesn't go along with their
narrative
here's how you know their their
narrative on race and white supremacy
and whatever other word you want to use
is bogus
look at what's happening in portland
right now there's a video just came out
of a man getting brutally beaten in
portland
happens to be a white guy by the way
who's getting beaten up
you got a group around them blm antifa
oh then a guy just kicked him in the
head
a lot of n-word being thrown around here
which we have bleeped out
as as one does that doesn't look good
that guy doesn't seem to have a whole
lot of white privilege so what happened
you know you look at that you say gosh
what could that guy have done to deserve
it you know what that guy did to deserve
it
he was sitting in his car sitting in his
truck when a group
of these blm and antifa thugs
surrounded him and got themselves into
and got him especially into a very
dangerous
situation
they walk up
[Music]
blm activists some antifa maybe two
showing up screaming at this guy who's
sitting in his truck
a lot of them they got probably what
eight or nine over here they start
attacking some
woman
at this point the guy's gonna get out of
his car to try to help skip ahead so the
guy finally says this is not a good
situation
he slowly drives out of there make sure
he doesn't run anybody over and then he
finally
starts to drive faster well eventually
he crashes his car he's obviously very
nervous
and the blm and antifa thugs pull him
out of his car
and just wreck this guy you probably
haven't heard very much about him cnn
doesn't talk about that guy very much
not a lot of articles in the new york
times about him
ask yourself this if that had been a
black guy
or any minority any person of color i
don't know whatever term the left is
using these days
if that had not been a white guy and it
was a political event
and and in any way you could tie the
rioters demonstrators anything
to the right wing the proud boys or
whatever else
if you could tie them to the right in
any way
you think you would have heard about
that i think you probably would have you
think that would be national news i
think it probably would be you think it
would be international news
very possibly it would so why are these
incidents treated differently
because one of them feeds a left-wing
narrative on race
that is politically advantageous to
democrats and
one of them does not one of them
either says nothing about that narrative
or counters that narrative so you're not
going to hear about it
meanwhile you're going to hear a lot
more about white supremacy but if we
lived in a white supremacist country
don't you think that that media
situation would be the opposite
i think there's some people who
genuinely believe we're living under
white supremacy
oh i don't where's the evidence for that
there's no evidence there's
just the conspiracy theory cooked up
by the left and propagated by some of
the biggest people in media
and they're open about it you know we've
talked on this show before about how
you know conservatives tend not to
consider our race
or our ethnicity to be our primary
identity category
see if you ask me hey michael what are
you i'd say i'm catholic i'm american
i'm
a new yorker original i live in la i'm a
podcaster i'd have all of these
different
identity groups maybe i'd get down
sicilian italian a little
a little english in there mixed in you
know a little mayflower in there
maybe way way way down and say oh i'm a
white guy too you know they always talk
about
how i'm a white guy but i guess yeah
sure okay way way way down
but for the left it's not like that for
the left race is the primary category
so if if race is the primary category
what's it look like
well and according to the mainstream
media white is a bad thing
it's an epithet that's why this word
karen which is a racial epithet it's
considered socially acceptable
specifically explicitly refers to white
women and you're allowed to say that
this derogatory term
but if if there were any comparable term
to refer to black women or
hispanic women or asian women or
whatever you you could be arrested for
saying that
it would be so socially unacceptable you
would at least be ostracized
but white woman it's okay i hope you
enjoyed that short segment from the
michael knowles show be sure to check
out the full episode linked in the
description or
download the podcast wherever you listen
to podcasts